[Music]
hi I'm welcome to episode number 80 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
hi I'm Francis campoy and I'm here with
my colleague Mark Mandel hey Mark how
are you doing I am very well today how
are you doing Frances and the most
excellent ever ever been I am very happy
we're going to be continuing the
conversation with Christopher Sanson
product manager for container builder
but today we're going to be talking
about kind of continuation I want to say
in the topic of CI CD continuous
integration continuous deployment about
speaker yeah and we will also have
Steven Kim and he's a software
engineering manager for the spinnaker
team here at Google yeah super super
love this talk it really does
I think explain the difference between
CI NCD and when you want to use one and
use the other yeah and really if you
don't know what spinnaker is at all this
is gonna be a good interactive
introduction because I did not know what
it was until then so yeah lots of things
to learn and we're gonna start from
really the beginning so it's kind of fun
and after that we will go into the
question of the week we touched on this
last week with the cloud source
repositories going general availability
but we're gonna talk a little bit about
the free tier just so people can
understand exactly how they can take
advantage of that and how that relates
to pricing as well yeah I think that the
wording was a little bit confusing so
we're gonna clarify what it actually
means and what is free and how much it
costs when you have to pay yep but
before that we're going to go whether
with other cool things of the week and
we have a bunch of them the first one is
an episode adds an episode a blog posts
are ran by our dear coworker I met up
cam he works here at Google she's a
software engineer in the kubernetes
valper relations team and he wrote a
blog post on what are the coolest
features of Google container builder so
you can either read that blog post or
listen to the previous episode they all
do both well he does cover some stuff we
don't talk about in the previous episode
which is super cool and gives you like
examples with like g-cloud commands of
exactly how you can use container
builder to do certain things like local
builds and stuff like that so you should
do both you should do both yeah
then we also have a blog post it's
called
nodes I and
how to prioritize and communicate risks
and it's part of the serious CRE life
lessons theory as you might all know a
series stands for customer reliability
engineering and we had an episode on
this back we look stone in episode 72 so
if you want to know a little bit more
about that definitely check it out but
also this blog post is actually very
interesting one I think you read it ya
know I really love this blog post we've
been talking exactly we've Luke Stone
several episodes we've done with Paul
Newton talking about sre as well I start
a liability engineer those two very very
related the blog post is all about how
they do a application liability review
basically when they sit down with people
they're going to support and say okay
where are your risks like where can
things go wrong and then also what sort
of SLO is SLS do you want to have in
place for these things and so once we've
identified the risk they can provide
recommendations on how to eliminate and
mitigate that based on their experiences
and it goes through step by step it does
things like risk matrices and then like
expected losses it's actually really
cool so if you're interested in starting
to do SRA or are you already doing s
every type things in the company you
work for I would definitely give this a
read it might give you some new ideas
and new approaches on how you can manage
these risks and how they relate to your
SLO and Escalades within your company
that sounds really interesting
especially knowing that you know Siri
they work with very big customers so
having the kind of like the guidance of
this is the kind of things you should be
doing yep to be considered to work with
Siri
that's perfect very very useful
information and then we have one last
one is actually a personal blog post no
personal blog post but a personal blog
post series yep from our dear teammate
Sheryl Chen yeah so Sheryl started this
series called the eliezer effect it's
not specifically all about Google Club
but she talks a lot about artificial
intelligence and machine learning where
she's had a series of blog posts that
are really really good so I just kinda
want to highlight them because they're
fantastic I particularly like the one
where she talks about explaining AI to
kids yeah that's the one I was looking
at which is is super super cool she's
actually traveled the world teaching
artificial intelligence and programming
to a wide variety of students all around
the world and so it's it's just super
cool and she sort of she weaves
pop-culture references through it to
explain it to children it's
it's really really impressive actually
not only pop references but also she
makes a reference to the imitation game
which is the movie about Alan Turing yep
she's not a film that I really love
partly because it stars Benedict
Cumberbatch and I just like his name
fair enough
awesome well I think that's probably I
mean there are so many cool things but I
think that's enough for today
why don't we go chat to our friend
Stephen and Christopher and talk all
about spinnaker sounds good let's do
that today I am delighted to have
Christopher Sanson product manager and
Stephen Kim software engineering manager
both of which on the spinnaker product
for joining us today how are you both
doing Chris doing great thanks it's time
didn't you Stephen you're doing well
yeah it's been a wonderful week so far
excellent well thank you so much for
joining us today and coming to talk to
us about spinnaker I love to learn more
about it but before we do that why don't
we talk a little bit about who you are
and what you do Christopher you want to
go first
great sure so I'm the product manager
for spanker and the larger cloud sea icd
experience and I am the engineering
manager for the Google spinnaker team in
the developer tooling section of Google
so if I'm not completely mistaken and my
memory is not failing you
you were also here for container builder
episode last week isn't that right
Christopher yes that is correct a
product manager for container girl in
spinnaker sort of the complementary
piece of our overall cloud sea icd
experience cool so why don't we get
started with spinnaker and you tell us a
little bit from a very high-level point
of view what is it and why people might
want to use it sure so spinnaker is a
open source multi-cloud continuous
delivery tool and it's used by companies
enterprises for release management for
deploying container images artifacts deb
packages into production cloud
environments and it's used basically for
development teams to deploy applications
quickly reliably and safely from from a
historical point of view when the
spinnaker happened like we just launched
it well we you just launched
the 1.0 version of spinnaker but tell us
it repaid what are the origins of the
zip of this project yeah yeah spinnaker
were announcing 1.0 just now but what
that really follows in the wake of a
tremendous amount of concerted effort
that multiple teams have put together to
arrive at where we are so spinnaker as a
project started inside Netflix about
three years ago and it's the way that
they wanted to do their deployments
internally and then about two and a half
years ago or so Google joined in and
this is prior to spinnaker being known
externally at all it's been sort of a
private project inside Netflix and then
in November of 2015 we announced open
sourcing to the public there was a lot
of good coverage around that and since
then we've had a number of organizations
come on and adopt it for their own
deployment purposes but we knew that
there were a lot of things that needed
to be done still to really make it ready
for mass adoption and people who they
don't want to have to tinker with it too
much for it to be successful in their
respective organizations so that's what
we've been working toward for the last
year and a half or so and that's what
the 1.0 is a culmination of so that's
really interesting I'm curious though
what were the problems that spinnaker
was built to solve that weren't
currently covered by existing solutions
in this space like were there particular
things that were a problem or is there a
particular aim for this project yeah I
mean spinnaker inside Netflix for those
of you are familiar with the project
named Asgard which was also developed
internally at Netflix spirit spinnaker
is sort of a spiritual successor to
Asgard and what Netflix recognized
internally is that you know they are
sort of the poster child for early
adoption of public cloud with AWS
and back then it was really bearer
infrastructure-as-a-service and there
was very little tooling out there so
automatically what Netflix did very
successfully is build a set of canonical
tools internally and what that
effectively did is it raised the
infrastructure as a service to a
internal platform of assert as a service
as of sorts right and so the problems
that they were trying to solve is to
create a canonical way across Netflix by
which
joints are made out to their a public
cloud and what that means is taking a
specific set of opinionated approaches
best practices lessons learned about how
deployments should be done that's some
that we can talk about throughout this
conversation does that mean that
spinnaker is specifically done for a
micro service architecture or can I use
it if I'm just like deploying to virtual
machines yeah as spinnaker certainly has
things that it is first and foremost was
built on top of but throughout sort of
the the usage across time we have taken
on additional use cases and so today
spinnaker supports both VM based
deployments as well as container based
deployments and then actually also
things like App Engine and OpenStack as
well and although you could say that it
was built on a microservices premise it
certainly goes and works with a number
of different ways that you can go and
choose to use spinnaker so spinnaker has
certainly a set of opinions and it's
very prescriptive about how to do
certain things like immeuble
infrastructure and you know Bluegreen
deployments and so forth but that
doesn't stop you from using it how you
want to go and use it and decide for
yourself what is the right increment
across time to do so nice so this is a
tool that Netflix created to help
themselves making their deployments more
automated while running on AWS why is
Google involved that's good question
Google recognized that for our GCP users
we wanted to go and provide a robust
toolset that follows in lines with a lot
of opinions that Google actually has
internally on how we do deployments so
that's something that I think it's fair
to say we have a lot of practice at a
lot of mistakes were made a lot of
lessons learned and we have a set of
opinions that we follow on how software
deployment should be made that's how you
know Netflix does 4,000 deployments a
day that's how Google does 25,000
releases a day you don't just do that by
accident it's through a lot of lessons
learned so we were looking for a way to
go and do this externally and when we
ran into the spinnaker project that
Netflix was doing
we found a kindred
you know on similar types of problems
similar types of scale and similar
priorities so we jumped in and at the
time Netflix was deploying almost
entirely to VMs so AWS ec2 s so we
started with adding GCE VM support with
the intention that an ongoing basis we
would continue to pour in our best
practices for our GCP users and a simple
example that is we very quickly followed
up with support for kubernetes and app
engine and then a whole bunch of other
things that we that were founded based
on things at Google ona so you mentioned
- there is a kubernetes I'm assuming
container engine app engine are there
any other internal projects that this
supports deployment - or those just the
only - yeah the foulest is like AWS ec2
GC VMs app engine kubernetes or gke and
typically the kubernetes running on you
know II C 2 s or GC VMs or bare-metal
also supports Microsoft Azure OpenStack
and there's a couple of others that are
in flight right now such as DC OS
maysville sphere DC OS is in flight
Oracle cloud bare-metal is also in
flight right now that's pretty much
complete that should be coming up pretty
soon and I'm sure we'll have many more
to go and analysis time goes forward
cool so that means that basically anyone
could be using spinnaker because you
know it's like no matter what you're
running spinnaker will run for you and
it's also open source I'm gonna say that
I'm assuming at least yeah it's open
source so social means two things that
are important to us one of them is that
it's free and number two is that we
welcome pull requests and so we're very
much also focused on building the right
community at scale and then
sustainability so I have a question that
I asked every single time but what
language is this version hey Christopher
all languages are written in Swahili
and that is the best answer anyone has
ever given spinnaker is is written in
Java groovy and actually a lot of Kotlin
is beginning to make its way in and then
of course the front end the web
components are written by the standard
you know jeaious and CSS and HTML
actually my question way was going was
like anyone anyone can use spinnaker
because it's open source and it's
available to deploy basically any
platform but who should be using it yeah
that's that's a great question so I
think if you look at why spinnaker
created it and why we've seen companies
like Waze and target adopt it you know
the the solutions out there in the
continuous delivery space are not as
robust is on the CI side of things so
what we're seeing people do is you know
stitch together a bunch of Jenkins
scripts to recreate essentially the
functionality that comes out of the box
of spinnaker like doing a Bluegreen
deployment or a rollback and it's pretty
complicated to do that you could do with
Jenkins you could do anything with
Jenkins but it was really designed for
that purpose and so people are having to
build their own tools or are coming from
a configuration management background
where they're using things like chef and
puppet to update running machines versus
using immutable infrastructure to deploy
an updated fleet of servers so
enterprises that care about uptime care
about higher velocity releases would
benefit a lot from spinnaker without
having to recreate the wheel themselves
because these are sort of fundamental
requirements for their business but not
knowing about spinnaker a lot of people
have sort of have gone to a lot of
effort to do what spinnaker does for you
so you mentioned something that I think
is quite interesting you you said these
phrase Bluegreen deployment could you
explain a little bit for audience what
does that mean sure so blue green or red
black as it's actually called in the
spinnaker world is so it's at a point
where you essentially deploy a new
version of your application to another
running fleet but you keep your old one
around and you just simply move your
traffic over from your old service to
your new service but you don't spin down
the old one quite yet you leave it
around in case
there's an issue or a bug and need to do
a rollback then it simply as easy as
Reed averting your traffic back to the
original versus having to sort of spin
it up or redeploy from scratch and also
it's worth mentioning blue green or
black red black strategy is one that we
can go ahead and point to but obviously
it's not a one size fits all so some
organizations might say blue green
deployments inherently require two X
number of resources to go into a
deployment that is not tenable for them
so we hear that loud and clear we're
working on other things like what we
call rolling red black for example which
makes better use of resource overhead so
you know if you're interested in hearing
more about that is you definitely check
that out on the website to get more
details Christopher you said something
almost in passing there too and you said
like basically the spinnaker seems to be
a tool just for enterprise or you just
use the word Enterprise in a sentence
I'm wondering right if I'm part of a
small team or like wind should I get
started with spinnaker is probably like
the best question yeah that's a good
question so I think if you are
experiencing any pain around releasing
your application it might be worth
looking at I think that since Bittaker
is open source you do have to stand up
your own instance it's not a hosted SAS
service we as part of this one put on
launch we're launching a new who called
halyard which is a CLI command line tool
for installing and configuring spinnaker
so for people that have tried spinnaker
in the past how you're greatly lowers
the barrier for getting up and running
yourself so I think if you are a
development team that kind of does your
own DevOps
using cloud services and are comfortable
in that world that you could benefit
from spinnaker you know I think what a
lot of people move from is or start with
is this sort of post build script
deployment you know though as part of
their CI system they'll do a
fire-and-forget deploy post build
they'll do cubic I'll apply or g-cloud
app deploy something like that if that
works for you great but I think at some
point most companies are looking for a
more sophisticated more stable
deployment strategy there's an inherent
aspect of a question you're asking which
is when does it become worth the
overhead of operating spinnaker right
for your organization to think about
reaping the benefits that spinnaker
brings and really to the limit we hope
that operationalizing
that's a word moniker approaches a0
another interesting in analogy to make
is for those of you who are familiar
with app engine startup teams and small
development teams loved App Engine
because it was very easy to go deploy
code and all they need to do was concern
themselves with developer concerns which
is writing features and then App Engine
as a platform would go ahead and deploy
that for you and if you look at App
Engine it's a runtime but it's also a
set of front-end services right that
allow you to go and deploy code and
manage load balancers and traffic and so
forth that's what was really neat about
App Engine so if you imagine as an
analog kubernetes is a platform it's an
excellent and wonderful runtime platform
and then right now we are doing a lot as
a community the kubernetes community
trying to go and make the tooling in
front of it much easier so imagine if
spinnaker or that front-end tooling
where to the limit that setting up
spinnaker becomes a no ops operation
then you would prefer to go and do your
deployments and community starts to look
a lot more like App Engine or for
example if you simply go to push code to
repository out of the box without
writing your own Jenkins scripts or
whatever it might be that it comes out
of the box configure to take that code
build a container and then go and deploy
it out to a running kubernetes cluster
so you're actually almost raise a good
point there so if I'm using App Engine
or I mean the deployment tools for
kubernetes they're actually quite nice
so you can do rolling updates red
green's not so hard why then do I want
to put spinnaker in front of it what
part is that in that story that makes
this very compelling yeah I mean App
Engine definitely provides a lot of
atomic operations to go ahead and do
things like cut over traffic a be
testing and so forth but it's a little
more difficult in a low-level for you to
go to script that right so you need to
make g-cloud calls to go to make those
updates with spinnaker we have pipelines
by which can then create a repeatable
and and and really a workflow for
yourself that then grows with you and
matures over time that you go and get
feedback from and so forth right it's a
benefit of autumn automating these
things yeah this this is a really
important point so the way this ways you
use Spinnaker's that you create
pipelines deploying to different
environments that you specify and as
part of that pipeline you define stages
and so those stages can be a lot of
different things they can be a manual
approval it could be a container job
but jenkins script and so it's not
simply the act of deploying but it's the
it's the verification of validation that
you do as part of your deployment or
even prior to saying that yes this is
production-ready code so running load
tests things like that that that's
simply focusing on just the just the
deployment piece doesn't get you and you
know I'll take the part to emphasize the
other side of that coin which is the
infrastructure mutating operations that
spinnaker supports are very very special
and this is a significant so for example
if you start with Jenkins today you're
typically interacting with your cloud
platform via you know embedded G cloud
commands inside your Jenkins jobs and
stages and so forth right well spinnaker
comes out of the box first-class
cognizant of all the platform and the
respective operations and here's what
that means if you want to do like our
our tagline that we talked about is to
do safe deployments and what that means
is this is a supervised safe deployment
so that when something fails in the
numerous sequence of things that you
have to do to the platform to do things
like blue-gray deployments that
spinnaker comes out of the box
understanding the sequence of things
that need to go to complete and how you
need to Golden Goal those things back
and what that means is out of the box a
lot of the work that you would have to
do to really see that to full
realization is done for you out of the
box and that's different for GC VMs
versus the kubernetes api versus the
azure API for example right and that's
what the benefit of supporting multiple
clouds out of the box actually means
awesome started talking about steps it
made me think about container builder so
I'm wondering now what is the
relationship between container builder
and spinnaker are they competitors and
you have a very interesting job or or do
they work together how does this work
they are they are they are best of
friends
so container builder is really around
your build and test workflow what we see
for for containers or if you're building
a Deb package is that container builder
you can set up your triggers on source
and so you make a change the source you
build and test your release candidate
you put it somewhere even do a docker
registry or artifactory or something
like that or GCS s3 what have you and
then that new release
it kicks off your spinnaker release
pipeline and so you know as you say like
build steps you know you have a certain
number of processes or transformations
that you want to make against your
source code as you build your artifacts
so we run a unit test integration test
things like that and then there's sort
of a different set of stages that you
want your now release candidate to pass
through as you deploy it and so they're
really two sides of the same coin and
it's kind of the CI and C D sides it
gets a little more complicated than that
in the sense that you can trigger
spinnaker pipelines from get events and
you can actually do a CLI based
deployment from container builder as a
build step I will leave that to power
users to find out but this this simple
story is a is one of tying together
container builder plus a registry to
spinnaker cool so just like it's 100%
clear like a user would sit down and be
like all right so I'm going to do the
continuous integration I'm going to use
a product like container builder or
maybe Jenkins or Travis or whatever to
do my integration my tests make my build
artifacts what I'm done and then I'm
going to take spinnaker to actually take
those artifacts and deploy them into the
cloud in a very safe manner so yeah that
the reactor that's a very typical
workflow spinnaker has first-class
integrations with Travis CI and Jenkins
so you can kick off pipelines from those
CI systems directly and yeah if that's
your entry point you know you have this
thing being built already and now I want
to deploy it cool so we're going to
running out of time but I wanted to ask
one last question I'm convinced I want
to use spinnaker what's the next step
what do we do sure yeah absolutely so
spinnaker IO is the website we encourage
people to go there the easiest way to
get started is there is a cloud launcher
instance so you can use Google cloud
launcher to spin up a spinnaker instance
on a VM you'll also see at spinnaker IO
for people that are looking to do more
production grade deployments you can use
the CLI tool I mentioned halyard which
inside your Google project does some
nice things like if you're deploying to
kubernetes or gke and stand it up your
spinnaker instance on kubernetes you
could follow a walkthrough we have for
for get it set up in you know about 15
20 minutes we also have getting started
code labs and then short videos that you
can go to watch there like five minutes
to help you understand what we see as a
golden path flow for different kind of
deployments that we typically see out
also what God and definitely link those
in the notes awesome and before we wrap
up what's next is there stuff on the
road map for spinnaker that you can
share with the audience we just got 1.0
out the door
so we'll see we don't have too much just
everything know but absolute there's
eggs there's actually a lot of really
exciting things coming out the door soon
so one of the big requests we get is for
configuration driven pipeline management
so we're working out something called
declarative continuous delivery where
spin occurs primarily UI driven although
there is an API and JSON for managing it
that way but we're simplifying config
driven pipeline templates for sharing
between teams and getting set up easier
another real interesting one is
automated canary analysis so we talked
about rolling red-black deployments and
traffic splitting and this then
integrates with monitoring services so
stack driver data dog and Prometheus to
evaluate your deployment and then make
automated judgments based on how it's
looking around error rates and queue
latency and automatically continuing
with your release or rolling it back for
you which is pretty cool awesome well we
are running out of time unfortunately I
think we could talk for a while is there
anything else that we haven't mentioned
or you want to make sure is plugged or
something special going on that didn't
get mentioned during the podcast yeah I
think we have a couple events on the
west coast this month we have a meet-up
in San Francisco on the 20th that we
encourage people to come to it's a very
active community I would say I don't
think we gave enough credit to the
community as we sort of talked about
mostly the product itself we have a very
active slack Channel it's joined us
Pinacate oh there you go but for a lot
of like new users and once you go
through the walkthroughs if you have
questions the community is very active
on slack including including the Google
engineering team here and we would love
to see people on there and don't be
afraid to Tapan and ask those questions
right well thank you so much so both of
you for taking the time today to tell us
a little bit about spinnaker and all the
cool things we chicken you can do with
it
great thank you guys all right thanks
very much and I'll be here next week
Thanks
so thanks again to Steven and
Christopher for such an interesting
conversation I definitely learned a lot
of it spinnaker partly because there was
a lot that I did not know yeah but a
very interesting conversation and
going to see where we can use it we said
container builder is something we're
going to be using for sure with the
podcast maybe spinnaker is the next step
who knows who knows cool so we've got
our question of the week we mentioned
this last week about cloud source
repositories going general availability
but the documentation is a little
confusing
I might shy away from that so basically
it says cloud source repositories is
free for up to five project users per
billing account and then when you
actually dig into the pricing on that as
well it says once you go over five
project users it's one dollar per
project user over five project users per
month it's like what is a project user
yeah it is pretty confusing especially
because it's like what does it mean to
access you mean that I have access or
that I do access it alright so what we
did we simply go and ask so we asked our
dear friend Chris sells he's a product
manager here at Google cloud platform
and we've had them at the podcast twice
we had him on episode number five long
time ago on developer experience and
then again we had him for episode 49
with Windows and net so we asked him and
his answer was basically saying the
important thing to know is it is not
about the potential of accessing a
project that counts is actually
accessing that project okay so if I'm
working on something and I go and I pull
something out of github
that's me accessing it well not github
but so no gap they get repository on the
source repositories repository yeah and
this is reset per month which means that
for instance let's say that let's say
there's two ways I could see the price
I'm the only person right there and I'm
working on four different projects this
month yep and then next month
I work in four complete different
projects that is four projects a month
and four projects the other so
everything is free it doesn't count as
eight because I access eight project in
total and the same way if you have let's
say one single project but you have four
people right and you have four people
one month and then the month after that
is four completely different people
that's so four people I'd seal for
people and for people it's not eight
people or any point yep therefore you do
not pay for
so let's talk a bit about like a project
user as well just very quickly so that
that's understood as well yeah so that's
the combination of the unique
combination of a project in a user so if
I personally one person use one project
that's one project user if I go up and
use two projects that's two project
users if franceska and I both use two
projects that's four project users yeah
because they're it's the unique
combination of those two things indeed
it is we actually count
did you actually access it or not it's
not about like the potential access
through I am or whatever No
did you actually access it or not I
believe this stuff is gonna get updated
so it will become clearer but for now we
complain a little bit we told our dear
product managers that the communication
in the ounces was not as clear as it
should so hopefully by the time you
listening to this episode it had been
fixed already
alright francisc I believe at the moment
you're in Buenos Aires no I just came
back that was last week I am now back
and yesterday was my birthday yeah
birthday
thank you everyone send pictures of
puppies different tasks yes please
I love puppies and actually my next
trips gonna be I'm gonna be in New York
for cucum yeah I'm gonna be running a
workshop on go tooling in action I made
a video a long time ago we should have a
link to this this video in the show
notes it was pretty successful because
like it teaches you how to use like
performance profiling and debugging and
stuff like that very cool and I'm making
that a workshop and I'll be running a
cucum and I'll be also try to probably
go see if I can organize something with
dgdg or to go meet up or something if
you are in New York and you like to
organize some event related to go in
Google cloud let me know send me an
email
sounds good what about you you see me
holidays I am still on holidays right
now oh my god I know it's great oh
that's so good but excited to be back
when I get back got some secret projects
working on I have a few more blog posts
that I'm working on on my series about
communities and game service as well so
keep an eye out for that as well awesome
and I'm thinking that by the time these
episode comes out I should have been
able to release the connects just for
[ __ ] it
I hope so but that is in the future so
I'm really hoping here I mean it'd be
like seven days late so probably
absolutely yes awesome well Francis
thank you once again for joining me on
the podcast for another episode thank
you Mark
and thank you all for listening and
we'll see you all next week
you